[Music]
friends fans around the world were
devastated when Matthew Perry died at
the age of 54 as were his fellow
co-stars now following a heartfelt group
statement from the cast Matt LeBlanc has
penned his own tear jerking goodbye
LeBlanc who starred as Chan Le Bing's
goofy roommate Jerry trani wrote in an
emotional Instagram post Matthew it is
with a heavy heart I'd say goodbye the
times we had together are honestly among
the favorite times of my life it was an
honor to share the stage with you and to
call you my friend I will always smile
when I think of you and I'll never
forget you never spread your wings and
fly brother you're finally free much
love fittingly LeBlanc ended his tribute
with a joke by saying and I guess you're
keeping the 20 bucks you owe me in
addition to his emotional Words which
reflect on their enjoying friendship the
Blanc shared several stills of Joey and
Chandler together highlighting just how
hilarious and adorable the duo were on
Friends honestly it's hard to imagine a
more memorable sitcom Duo the true
definition of Opposites Attract The
Lovable goofballs were frequently atted
with one another though they never Shi
away from Mutual admiration their
various escapades and side quests led to
some of the most memorable plot lines in
France such as the time they adopted a
chick and a duck and who can forget
their hilarious banter in London during
Ross's
wedding you're different here
too you're mean in
England to this day the Duos Bromance
stands out as a major highlight of the
show and surprisingly LeBlanc and Perry
carried their onscreen relationship
outside of the show's bustling set back
in 2015 while speaking with the
television critics Association press
tour LeBlanc gushed over his co-star he
said I love that guy I could not see him
for 5 years and then get in a room
together and still have a short hand
with each other it's amazing really Mara
Blanc and Perry were both quite private
they were occasionally seen together one
of the Duo's most heartfelt crossovers
was when the Blan showed up to support
Perry for his debut play the end of
longing back in 2016 LeBlanc shared in
an Instagram post he and the cast were
great where to go bro clearly the two
genuinely cared about each other as of
this video leblanc's Instagram post as a
first major solo statement released from
a friend's cast member following Perry's
death while the core cast of Friends was
no doubt close as evidenced by the 2021
Max reunion special Matthew Perry wished
that he could see his former co-stars
more often he told a Hollywood in
2022 uh we don't see each other as much
I wish I wish the group had SE see each
other more Perry has always been candid
and honest about his relationship with
his co-stars frequently praising them at
every opportunity in his 2022 Memoir
friends lovers and the big terrible
thing Perry opened up about his brutal
history with addiction in an excerpt
released by the Sunday Times Perry
discussed how LeBlanc helped him stay
awake on set he wrote but still the
addiction ravaged me one time in a scene
in the coffee house when I'm dressed in
a suit I fell asleep right there on the
couch and disaster was averted only when
Matt LeBlanc nudged me awake right
before my line no one noticed but I knew
how close I'd come in the same exerpt
Perry revealed how Jennifer Aniston once
confronted him regarding his addiction
describing the encounter as devastating
while they continued to be private about
their personal lives it's obvious that
the Friends cast deeply care for one
another if you or anyone you know needs
help with a addiction issues help is
available visit the Substance Abuse and
Mental Health Services Administration
website or contact samsa's National
helpline at 1800 662 help
[Music]